[Music]
this day is set upon a mighty endeavor a
struggle to preserve our civilization
and to set free a separate humanity
our sons pride of our Nik
leave them straight to prove Call of
Duty's long-awaited return to its World
War two roots is not only a homecoming
but also a commemoration of the powerful
bonds that form between brothers and
arms yes connecting with strangers
through online matches and the zombies
mode isn't unusual but Call of Duty
World War two's moving campaign also
salutes the Brotherhood that grows and
strengthens on the battlefield the end
result is a game that delivers
practically everything that one looks
for in a pick-up-and-play shooter set in
the Western Front of World War two while
also breaking free of pall of duties
formulaic trappings a first-person
shooter set during the journey from
Normandy to the Rhine isn't unique but
you haven't quite experienced anything
like the tour of Ronald Daniels and the
1st Infantry Division in Call of Duty
World War 2 it's a substantial six plus
hour Trek where intense close quarters
combat complements spectacular showcase
events brought to life through excellent
visuals and sound design we are all that
separates the world from darkness
it's so much more than a chance to be
heroes in our own lifetimes we prevail
our triumphs will be etched into the
hearts and minds of a grateful world or
untold generations I'm talking about
glory gentlemen true glory a supporting
cast of well-crafted personalities
greatly enhances the narrative they
directly assist you during combat based
on your needs and performance their
contributions which include replenishing
health packs and grenades are tied to a
cool-down that decreases as you kill
enemies this kill driven method of
supply replenishment is undeniably
gamified but it's nonetheless a crafty
way to serve the narratives focus on
bonding with your squad combat is about
hunkering down at nearly every fallen
table picking off just enough Nazis to
give you an opening for the next cover
point and as you count on your squad for
supplies and recon support you feel
empowered as a valuable team member in a
company that has your back remember no
digging in at the shore gotta advance
you need to stay low and do not bunch up
stick your trainings you're gonna make
it through
a proudly gee fellas in the battle
anytime anywhere
naturally for going to future tech and
superhuman mobility of the last few
Cod's the return to mid 20th century
combat is especially welcomed in World
War two s adversarial multiplayer the
prevalence of tight and enclosed areas
make shotguns and submachine guns the
popular weapons of choice in team
deathmatch and other classic modes like
the territorially driven domination or
hardpoint if you're a sniper fan your
talents shined the brightest in war Call
of Duty World War two's version of
battlefields rush as a mode where one
side of attackers attempt to conquer
multiple segments of a map one section
at a time
it's multi-phase linear format makes it
a prime battleground for long-range
weapons the asymmetrical format of
assaulting and defending fits the d-day
invasion perfectly as one of the three
available operations all sorties proved
involving and satisfying
no matter the side which makes the
limited selection of three maps the one
drawback of this otherwise stellar mode
[Music]
whatever your preferred armaments Call
of Duty World War two's new division
class system excels by letting you make
the most of your specific play style
while offering the flexibility to
diversify your loadouts by joining the
expeditionary force for example you have
the exclusive benefit of incendiary
shotgun rounds but that doesn't mean you
can't switch to an assault rifle mid
match the more you play the more rewards
you earn that can be spent to hone your
personal armoury and abilities to suit
your needs
adding to your identity building are the
myriad cosmetic items you unlock by
opening supply crates which are awarded
regularly as you play this blind box
system plays out innocuously with no
pay2win shortcuts in sight at least in
the game's launch iteration tying these
adversarial multiplayer modes together
is the activity rich social hub aptly
titled headquarters this lively
gathering spot is an inviting site to
chill and train in ways impossible in
standard-issue multiplayer menus between
the cluttered user interface and the
long checklist of available objectives
headquarters feels overwhelming at first
but it speaks to the richness of this
area's practical and entertaining
activities headquarters even offers its
share of stimulating gunplay the marquee
match is in the 1 vs. 1 pit it's single
weapon stakes are socially enhanced by
letting those in the queue watch current
matches while they wait their turn
pairing cooperative play with the appeal
of a goal driven narrative zombies once
again proves it's worth as an essential
Call of Duty mode this survival mode of
fantastical fiction hits players against
waves of the undead in a Bavarian
village those who thrive on multitasking
will find the abundance of action items
and an e relentless influx of brain-dead
enemies
positively engrossing along with
naturally gaining a better familiarity
of the map and the many zombie types
repeat playthroughs reward players with
a host of meaningful upgrades and
quality of life conveniences from
passive buffs to custom loadout slots
compared to multiplayer loot crate's and
zombies play a much larger more
practical role adding to the modes value
as a compelling showpiece at the same
level of Call of Duty World War 2 s
other game types any given pack can
contain a game-changing consumable
whether that's a few free revives or a
couple zombie obliterating panzer
shrikes figuring out when to use these
valuable enhancements as part of the fun
I didn't sign up for the shite - none of
us do buts here we are and you have your
mission just as I have mine to find and
rescue the scientists who risked his
life to get us this intelligence Klaus
Fisher my brother I meant on take with
these Dalek
no search and rescue best of luck
[Applause]
what the hell was that ultimately if
every shooter set in the European
theater of world war two is measured by
how it depicts its d-day landing
assuming it has such a mission Call of
Duty World War two emphatically succeeds
in its impactful designs and deliveries
while not equally emotional this
battle's reinterpretation and war mode
proves to be a highlight in a superb
suite of competitive modes zombies
rounds off this stellar return to form
effectively blending the ferocity of
online cooperative play with the goal
driven satisfaction found in the
campaign as one of the most
comprehensive and filler free Call of
Duty's in recent memory Call of Duty
World War two successfully capitalizes
on a series of strengths and warrants
the attention of any first-person
shooter enthusiasts tonight
everything we lost everything we fought
for will mean something tonight we take
back our city
[Music]